you already know what it is baby is real
92.3 after-party bootleg calf DJ damaged
rape Sinatra in studio right now
I'll homie from Memphis Papa some I call
him the king of Memphis because it
covers a lot are you feeling man bless
me see you know Gliss shining shining
got that Rockefeller chain on there this
light was shining so long did I mean
how's everything uh you know officially
joined the Roc Nation family you know
I'm a hustler man you know and so on
every day I wake up on my own
ignite the hustle to be stronger and and
and greater so you know working with
something I like Jay and the whole team
over them you know they'll make sure I
put my point something and we close the
right situations and keep getting it you
know then what how did that come about
what made you you know make the
transition of roc nation I always admire
what je t'aime do you know me a lot of
moguls do is Jake Prince to muster P to
bird now to me all moguls always study
moguls and business people I don't
really study around us you know means I
always don't deal with my thing so you
know to UM to be been a partner with
somebody like Jay and his whole team
once you get in there you you understand
there's more than help you know I mean
it's a whole thing they ever paid over
there who who make anything Rock so you
know I mean it's almost me for real yeah
they're a lot of Records I know we
talked a few months ago New York over
Jez and you said that you had like mad
records with Kanye how many records have
we not heard yet did you work with Kanye
on oh no stuff that we haven't heard
though I'm assuming right I don't know
Mitch is like you know we're playing
able to blitz and to you know say is
because um it's experience you know
mouthing Kanye one the crazy people to
create music so just working with them
young me like I really like doing a song
right so you don't really go in and do a
feature for cutting yeah you know
they're like you just work you know
maybe you work in different X base so it
was like so
different things can come out of it you
know meaning who knows when they come
out how they come out what they sound
like when they finish because he's such
a great artist he heard and see it so
differently usually they could take
control of it that's what it is because
yeah a lot of people probably imagine
what it would be to be in a studio with
Kanye but for yo gotti when you step in
that studio what's that violin I mean
I'm a fan you know me so so first step
is like yelling is only cleaning it is
reality like Oh from the awesome play
you know I mean the bottom for real
don't ever get it twisted how much money
I'm making a success we don't I'm still
a fan of the game and the art and people
like and you know jzjz - meekly is
creating me like when I'm in the studio
with him with touring business with him
me who they are like I'm fans of death
so being in the rooms a longest
achievement for me yo back in the day
you was on TV t you put out underrated
project and then yeah I remember when
you left TV T you got on that mixtape
grind I was telling them isocell is [ __ ]
son of Yo Gotti mixtapes it is but not
was there like to be right I was going
to say like you know obviously you know
you come from the streets but it was
there for a point when you left TVT
records where you were doing anything
where you came close to kind of you know
going back two feet into the streets and
giving up on the rap game because
obviously you know that grind is real
that independent grinders yeah a lot you
play made for you know honestly man like
making home days I wanna say I was even
on the other streets right in the first
place right you know so I was just
blessed to stay focused enough and in
dodge enough situations to be here if
you know I'm saying so uh you know the
first project you taught my soul 150 150
thousand units and we were independent
so we've been making money for a long
time even was smaller looking small
right we was making money for a long
time you don't say so
numbers always be my theme math always
been my favorite subject one of the
things I told myself whether it was
throughout game of cutting yards or
whatever whenever I'm doing I'm gonna
get paid for it
good paid for it you gotta be nice oh it
was always my focus coming in again like
I said into business I never want to be
a broker Apple you know me at the end of
the day I'm a person who like you know
you go platinum 100 times and then your
mom again evict it or you can be very
didn't I don't was never cool to me so
even before I was oh hi will people
consider hot hot you know I figured out
a way to make the music business a
business for me you seem super smart to
like financially like every time I talk
to you like what work where do you have
your money at you got some real estate
some side businesses like you know a lot
of people you know obviously you talk
about moguls you know what I mean yeah I
mean I'm sure you you you you you're
investing correctly out there like you
have it if you can't like give something
back to somebody who got some extra
bread shelling like where would you tell
them to put them in real estate is like
I say like the simplest thing it's not
not super simple but like if you throw
discrete like real estate could be your
second thing easily right because it's
the same formula you know you buy
something you fix it up you sell it for
profit yeah it's just like being in the
street is really easy you know I mean I
mean I will get the the know the thing
to it is just knowing what the back and
buying curricula you know me know be in
a world with the market is great but
real estate should be pretty easy if
you're a hustler I just feel like if you
a hustler you should be able to do
anything like you know being like you
just look into it like everything all
the emphasis different products like I'm
cycling on me you gotta be selling dope
right here products change straight up
there you're saying like we some
additionally research sneakers or no
stock but whatever like I'm sorry come
on you gotta figure out like yourself
Sox will you get it in for the best
number and how you sell it for the best
number and your profit line between what
you working on oh my wait did you hate
on my sock right now you would sell
I don't know what is up here it was
wrong cellar so no I wasn't on a tray
when I was in high school I used to sell
pastries because my mom worked the
Entenmann's is so all the ones he was
gonna throw away I used to take the
store donuts and [ __ ] yeah but I got
come on don't wonder what made you want
to sign in money bags yo you know I'm
saying like money big yellow hot you
know mean even come across if you don't
want to do that you have betrayed see
that I was was a 250k cast out it was
something like but but this light you
know this light because he was way more
way way way more than there so I want
nobody get it twisted is like you know a
couple hundred thousand or money bear
your work could be dealing with like I
should have paid way more you know maybe
if you when you work to me and what he
went through itself is because it's
unlimited you know there but you know um
they're just song consider little bonus
one for those artisans you know that yo
gotti signing the CMG well what are you
looking for cuz I've noticed you see
black youngster you see money bag LD got
big personality I'm looking for
greatness
okay you know me like and what makes a
person great everybody individually you
it could be your personality it could be
your music definitely I feel swag it
could be your business it can be you
know I mean like what make you special
that what I look for in our artist like
I ain't just listening to your music you
know saying like I'm looking to see like
what the world on love about you and
then and maybe younger and we push evey
show or ple or something for the
ultimate hope people a rock by Southwest
I'm like yo I became like more of a fan
when I really seen her before
who's like you know what hey Shelly why
like you had the superstar quiet like he
was turned up more than anybody in the
bill got like a great up like okay I see
you now like after genius man for real
like like he'd either be great hustlin
cheese you know me and he know what he
doing he know he want to do we know you
won't be anyone achieve it you know say
hey James
he make you talk about him for sure
you cannot overlook but they say you
little horse give Thank You little horse
he got his own language man I'm trying
to figure out like how to understand it
you are sounding a lot of emerging
talent and this a question I did I think
you can answer best when do you break
that tie you know when you're coming
from the streets and you're starting to
do music how do you know when do you
know is that that time at that point in
your career where you got a cut the
street stuff out I mean you can even
know them different different that's
[ __ ] you don't know we just know your
guys might be well I mean me personally
like he got to a point with me why I
knew I was going to jail right you know
they're like little dick close you go
saying like when everybody around you go
and you know how things work you know I
operate the dominate ball yeah and it
was like when you wake up every day and
leave your house and go to the
neighborhood and do what you're doing
everyday for your life like addiction is
not just the people who take two take
two or whatever it is they take it it's
the lifestyle as well of just you being
in routine of doing the same thing every
day like you know there's like like
getting stop it from doing it I would
think is just as hard to stop me from
taking a substance you know saying so
like for me that was like when I figured
you know is either dis at it and I
started trying to like change the
pattern of you know me I got my first
office and I want even you know probably
doing enough business to have an office
but it was kind of like my place to go
and study going to the hood every day
right right
I was giving myself something else to do
like wake up be the house go to the hall
because I'm staying in house you know I
mean I ain't never been no house doing
out on time in the morning like even now
I'm in your studio and I just can't be
like inside of yeah please you know
there so I start going to the office
every day and every day and then and I
start being in the office I just start
thinking morning like you know cleaning
morning and making the office you know
every work that makes sense you ever
actually put yourself somewhere else
here hey is this young Dolph situation
never going to like get resolved
man cuz I know situation I feel like you
know he put out that the play with your
[ __ ] record and I just feel like you
kind of step back and let him do
whatever he's gonna do the tuition what
is the the you know I I just know that
you know dude obviously I'm not saying
you had anything to do with it but you
know some of the tempted on dudes life
in Charlotte no situation so it's no
situation on your land it doesn't it
definitely seems one-sided the way you
know the energy he's putting - you gotta
don't be in situations you got to give
money your guy helps artists come up and
build careers for their family I mean
y'all got it helps young catch from the
hood of change it's like you got it on
be in situations we don't get in the
negative or positive we get money so
you're not gonna be like red record from
God man this is no situation for you
guys man we get money you've got it
beating upon the LA Reid drinking
problem with jay-z we don't have
situations you know I mean we bless and
then we change lives we don't know it we
don't even see you know main things that
is this in their light I can dig that
respect
yeah I mean you got to be the bigger man
sometimes business yeah I feel both all
the time would you be prepared talk
about the new album man you got the
record I wife and Lucci this because he
knows [ __ ] man I like Lucia
understatement I just I just did it on
Jimmy Kimmel with Lucci yeah we saw that
yeah yeah you know me for me like um
Nestle bit you know any late-night TV
any of them things is accomplishments
for me you know I mean but it's a it's a
great accomplishment for me to be able
to like bring somebody like Lucci
wrong TV for me with me you know every
year there your name like it just feels
a home and Shannon is a thing for me too
I was Coachella man did you get with
anything dusty dusty ass foot features
ladies out there was walk around and
sandals and flower headdresses and I
ain't I ain't Kissin bank and I need
Coachella I should have but I was
telling something everybody
oh sure age stays I was kind of moving
kind of quick around any of my first
time at Coachella so angry to write
really like do a lot see a lot I mean I
get to see you like I was actually not
performing like I was on stage with
Kelly and then you know that time to go
Kelly you myself to get I had to go out
with marshmallow so like I really have a
lot of time in between to see you know
couple like like marshmallow obviously
EDM are artists in today's real popping
right now but like where's that
correlation come because a lot of people
might think that's random you know yeah
it may be render with marshmallow like
certainly you know sailing oh he
actually hit me and just reached out to
me and was like yo he's regular here I
think it was like they like not a record
um right just put out the latest project
and just really supporting the music you
know mean like oh this will real DJ's
built awful you know say amazing for
real like when somebody's big as
marshmallow reach out to you just
because he liked the music initially you
know I mean it and it starts the
conversation alright you know what you
got poppin what you're doing you know
what I'm in Vegas doing this all my
hello
i'ma come out and do the record with you
I flew in Vegas can't even out done the
record with me then we just you know
being connected and rockin with each
other a sense who saw using the studio
mic well and we got coming oh man that's
a situation right now it's like real
situation what else is a collaboration
wise you I know you always working with
somebody man
me and Mike we got some awesome things
coming sooner than later
big things come oh is that like a
project or you know just a couple of
joints maybe you know they got the new
thing out called playlist they don't
play list now or I'm gonna do what I'm
gonna do it so my clear out he'll so I'm
gonna pull up on in the night and then
figure out what he's gonna be okay okay
you know they're you know I almost
figure out what it going because we
asked them some Johnny you know after
you pull out y'all could pull back here
to Opie oh yes a little bit I will
figure out what it gonna be me I wanna
know is this somebody that you haven't
worked with that you want to work with
it we might not expect you know since
summer this like that I would never
expect God you don't want to work with
this artist oh it might be way off you
know you know what they brought me home
is there like I always want to work with
the with the non-obvious right like to
mediate no excite Simon on I don't like
to be predicted any way to meet in song
I mean I saw bees week like I believe in
power when things like that always like
the not knowing and not being able to
predict you know I mean so like I don't
want to do the records that people think
I want to do you know they're like like
it's interested me like I wanna rock on
marching right you know I mean like I
want to do a reckon for him with him you
know they're like that's what I really
want to do like I mean I could do a
track record with every traveler that
ever came out y'all know I can sound
with him before we put it out that's
real you know me you know Guardian via
record coming real soon reached out the
Kodak says he's been back in jail I know
you guys got the weatherman record is
that and if we totally engage three days
to but I reach out to contain people I'd
to check up on it like ESI boy there
yeah only K see what they turn around
what they doing on me codec one of my
favorite new hardest was like working
with him and he's like no they're
genuine man like I've been in this game
so long man like you know when somebody
just genuine to meet them the best
artists you know mean like black
youngsters and you know codec is like
when you around them which you heard
through the music is what you get is who
it is you know I mean like it when they
would issue thing cuz that's why it's in
German yeah but I'm saying like you know
somebody young as well just this part of
like when you think about hip-hop and
you think about artisans and the fans
like you know the fans won't the real
person that's real yeah you know Santa
and they said but they don't get the
real person a lot of time because so
many of these people so many artists you
know me they they are Street create
online do to Instagram lanes you know I
mean I won't say no names and I like
dang and then do no matter marketing
strategy videos am but but hey else add
a lot of these people you talk about you
know there
if you take away their social media post
as a Instagram they records what they
say what they saying in and you do your
real research do they name ever come up
in internet affiliation that you're
talking about
you can saying you're never gonna hurt
it you can say like I'm pretty sure you
is you know beyond that you know I mean
but any stories you heard about yo gotti
they ain't just companies Instagram
populate you everybody is it's real but
anyway Kodak like your main codec
reminds me of that that where you got it
come from with Young Jeezy come from a
boost it come from
it is real like you ain't no you know I
mean we he'll know we can create these
own pictures because greatness off of
twins and you know I mean we had litters
so it's helping and for people to know
the real when you look at a Kodak
situation right you know what it what is
that period do you think or who can who
could that person be that can help them
see maybe his actions might be taking
him somewhere else because at this point
looks like we're they're saying he may
be facing eight years you know I know
he's being itself I mean come on what is
the challenge you told I like to take a
lot of charges eight years of I don't
even know we did come on many people may
be going to the club
hey they prefer going to the club with
me for going to a boxing match right
come on never you got to be realizing
like the exam but but codec a superstar
think he gonna beat one you know I mean
and um he gonna figure it out you don't
say he don't figured how you got to tell
it you know man he got good people
around you know me in a day um we always
young at some point you know I mean we
just make different decisions you know
mean I say his decision was wrong
because I don't know the case I don't
know like I don't you know they're like
we see people get locked up everyday for
some mango yo coming out of Memphis
obviously like your influence might be a
little different than some other
southern artists but if you had to like
let's say god forbid you had to be stuck
on an island and go to jail for like
five years and you had an iPod with two
or three albums on it with your favorite
or three albums you would take with you
well I'll be listening to
and not your own [ __ ] or anybody funky I
feel really sure did I feel listened to
all I like like my rotation of music is
like what I consider classic music like
young jeezy truck with that or if you
think it rigid that trash like that Oh
Wayne Carter one you know ji8 juvenile
400° okay and i jump them the album's
like I like to listen to them straight
up all classics man all classics what's
up you got it you have anything like
like ProjectWise dropping soon I mean
yeah I guess gonna jump song yes is it
gonna just come out of nowhere my just
like cocaine Friday you know I'm glad I
put my we put ourselves in the position
where like we just do we want to do da
air like like we just go in the studio
we work at our own pace at our own time
and in in a relaxed feel or how we want
to work and we have no material then we
did decide this one we come in is how we
coming yes I see him G word you know me
that I'm black young stir work money bad
girl work anybody I'm rocking with like
they bosses a young bosses so you know
me ain't no you know no dead lands I
know you might you better have these
baddies you do these baddies is more
everybody I rock with we all partners
you know they're straight out you know I
want a lot of young bosses rumored up yo
gotti makes you get him on the Instagram
on the Twitter
birthday coming up soon too right yeah I
don't know what I'm gonna do for there
yet I'm trying to figure it out should
involve some some strippers or as your
friend were like say some [ __ ] little
board we go be a lot of then yo God we
appreciate you coming through my G